I have never seen or read Harry Potter I
just never got on board you know I mean
I don't read fantasy books the social
world has pushed Harry Potter intellect
on to me against my will based on what
you know tell me what you think the
story of Harry Potter is okay I think
Harry Potter is a poor kid who lives in
London and then one day a monster comes
into his room and then puts a Z on his
forehead with a stick
an owl flies to his house and tell them
that he's gonna be a witch him and his
friend Jacob and Hermione they left and
they went to Hogwarts they they get to
magic school and a wagon or something
the equipt over the head putting a wagon
and then they met gandalf though though
with the wizard the master wizard
there's a really smart house there's a
cute house there's an evil house and
then there's like a just house of people
that are generally kind and there he
trains with all of his friends to beat
the guy ghosts the monster who gave him
the Z in the forehead
he plays can't quit Quidditch breeches
which is a stick game where you hit a
pigeon with six in between two goals
that go like this Harry Potter and
Hermione fall in love during all of this
because she's like just sweet smart
feisty one and he's like needs her
around to like get through his life they
wear capes some of those capes
are adorned with Patronus says Patrona
there's a Patronus
someone's a werewolf at one point right
one of the teachers is a werewolf maybe
and then Voldemort killed Harry Potter
because he was being too nosy it was in
this like this golden room where it was
Voldemort and there was like a UH uh
like a like a bowl of water and it was
talking and he has this big fight with
him at the end nostril man I'm like guys
I feel like you like as the falls off so
I'm sort of
or something Romani put the wand in the
in the golden goblet there's powder in
there boom by the face of her friends
kill Voldemort and then Harry Potter was
wounded in the fight but didn't let you
know and then he dies about Hermione is
crying over him and it's really dramatic
yay
[Laughter]
[Music]